[Music]
[Music]
our relationship to images has an
economic relationship we walk towards
images and whatever is there has certain
scale that confirms the scale of our
body and our distance to it and as we
approach it something happens we either
find the connection or we lose it
Photography gives you the ability to
play with that scale once you go beyond
and you really blow the scale altogether
beyond that the boundaries of what we
understand economically this is the kind
of images that I am always interested in
to think that there is a grain of sand
on that castle in it you know it's not
just a trick
that's real I used to work in a very
small studio and my work had a certain
scale and then I realized that by moving
into a larger studio the word sort of
expanded in the beginning of the it I
think was around 2001 2002 I had the
opportunity to work in an environmental
scale we made almost 25 drawings some of
them up to a scale of 500 meters long
and they could only be seen from
helicopters the draw itself becomes
something from your mind
around at the same time it made me think
of going the opposite way around and
actually making things so small it would
create similar impression there will be
so tiny that it could only be imagined
it cannot be seen and it was a very
fortunate event that I ran into Marcelo
quaalude the first time the Vic talked
to me about this project I thought he
was joking he came to me he was like
I've had this idea for a long time and
have really been one thing to do this I
want to draw caso into a grain of sand
and I think the sheer impossibility of
it is what excited me and then from then
on it was basically trying to figure out
how to do it and that lasted about four
years project starts at pre photography
started using a camera lucida which is a
drawing instrument that Vic used to draw
this castles camera lucida is a 19th
century device that allows you to make
pictures it's something that allows you
to see what's in front of you projected
in a board right below it and all you
have to do is to trace it the inventor
of photography Harry Fox that was a
terrible camera lucida a draftsman
that's probably the reason why he
invented photography so we start before
cameras exist and we end up at a point
where cameras are kind of irrelevant or
they're not even necessary
[Music]
the machinery ultimately use is called
the FIB for focused ion beam it's
normally used in the electronic industry
for fixing integrated circuits instead
of use it your draw shapes for drawing
castles with it this is about half of a
millimeter and I'm trying to find the
grain that looks good all right so I
just loaded the image of the castle here
I'm going to frame it now on this screen
here we'll have the ions that we use to
etch the grain and on this screen we'll
have the electrons that we used to see
the grain and that the combination of
both is what creates damage and I would
just wait two minutes fingers crossed
it's really strange because you're
basically drawing onto a canvas you
don't quite know what it is and you
can't hold it sometimes I'll draw and
the grain will just break into pieces
because it's too soft or sometimes I
draw nothing will show up because it
might be too hard and you have to
restart the entire process I don't think
I've ever worked on something that was
this complicated and difficult over the
course of four years like sometimes I
ask myself should I just do this in
Photoshop but you realize that it's not
the same thing in some ways the final
image carries with it the history of the
process that you've developed
recognition has been the basic principle
my work since the very beginning the
word recognition is very interesting
because it means assimilating something
twice I rely on imagery that's very
simple things that you've seen a million
times because that's what creates this
little trick you think you know it and
then you have to know it again
the idea is that you create a path but
you leave bread crumbs for the viewer to
to follow and this questioning about the
image when you're looking at something
you realize how the hell was this done
[Music]
alright it looks like we've got
something here so this is the first
Castle that we got with this new batch
of grains it's actually really nice now
to sort of navigate through the image
and see some of the details when you
look at the castle in the drawing you
see the outlines of the rocks are there
on top of the top of mountains basically
and they actually match the actual
outline of the grain so this is really
interesting symmetry right where the
mountain actually looks like the grain
of sand and they're entirely different
scales
interesting thing about projects that
connect scientists and artists I think
it comes down to the point that we feel
that we're always looking for the same
thing you know we're trying to
understand the world around us I think
photography in some ways is just sort of
restarting and I think there's a whole
new kind of photography kind of emerging
now a lot of it is happening because of
this combination between computers and
cameras in a new form of storytelling
narrative can sort of emerge from it it
is a great moment to be a photographer
today because photography is completely
obsolete in terms of its relation to
reality we're pretty much at the spot
where painting was around 1839 when
photography was invented painting was
sort of released from its relation to
the factory world painters had to think
what is painting in a similar fashion
the relationship of between photography
and reality has changed significantly
with the advent of digital imaging it's
becoming what Leonardo mentioned is kosa
mentally is something from the mind
which has always been
when somebody tells you hey this is a
grain of sand there's this moment where
the reality that you have in front of
you sort of falls apart and you have to
reconstruct it you have to really take a
step back and rethink what that image is
and what it means and I think that's the
motivating force behind Rick's work and
why he wanted to do this project it's so
insignificant yet so monumental I'm very
happy with the result we should have
started with that
[Music]
you